[Musique]
tu as toujours eu une vision sinistre de
l'avenir
et de voilà en train de te battre pour
le sauver
je n'ai pas toujours eu une vision
sinistre de l'avenir
je voulais juste ne pas y apporter plus
de vie ça ne signifie pas que les gens
ne doivent pas être sauvés
sans tourner dans n'aurait pas été là
[Musique]
non tu ne serais pas là et si vous
pensez que c'est dur dans les villes
passer une journée sur le crise le
nombre de morts et trois fois plus
existe
première étape la toux c'était
tremblements c'est un peu comme une
lettre qui empoisonnent l'esprit et le
corps c'est vraiment dégueulasse
merci c'est une arme non c'est un remède
contre le virus pulmonaire tu sais
combien de personnes sont mortes à cause
de ça amenez moi juste être prudent de
mallettes
on y va il faut qu'on bouge
c'est le remède
[Musique]
où est elle
c'est à l'épreuve des balles j'en sais
rien tu veux utiliser cette caisse pour
arrêter des balles ou quoi [ __ ] c'est
sans moi cette sphère non
[Musique]